[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport ein guten Abend auch
von mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von heute
Leoparden für die Ukraine polen will
kampfpanzerliefern Deutschland als
Herstellerland will dem offenbar nicht
im Wege stehen
Wohnung verzweifelt gesucht wegen hoher
Kosten so zu wenig gebaut der
Wohnungsmangel ist so groß wie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht
und Tod einer Rocklegende
der britische Musiker Jeff Beck galt
vielen als Gitarren Gott jetzt ist er
mit 78 Jahren gestorben
[Musik]
helfen deutsche Kampfpanzer der Ukraine
diesen Krieg zu beenden oder erhöhen sie
das Risiko einer Eskalation die
Bundesregierung ringt mit einer
Entscheidung Vizekanzler Harbeck
plädierte heute dafür zumindest die von
Polen geplante Lieferung nicht zu
behindern gestern gab es das Signal von
Polens Präsident du da an seinen
Kollegen selensky Leopard Panzer in die
Ukraine zu liefern das geht aber nur
wenn Berlin zustimmt weil die Panzer aus
deutscher Produktion stammen
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 ist einer der
leistungsfähigsten seiner Art seit Ende
der 1970er wird er produziert er ist
beweglich relativ schnell und kann bis
zu 5000 Meter entfernte Ziele Treffen
über die panzerdebatte Christiane
hübscher
Christine Lambrecht in Sachsen bei den
beiden Marder Kompanien die Deutschland
im Ernstfall in den NATO-Einsatz schickt
als Ersatz für die defekten Pumas die
Ministerin würde hier gerne nur über die
Schützenpanzer sprechen aber die
Diskussion ist schon weiter wird
Deutschland auch Kampfpanzer in die
Ukraine schicken es gibt keine
Entscheidung in der Bundesregierung
Kampfpanzer abzugeben diese Entscheidung
ist nicht getroffen und deswegen stellt
sich diese Frage auch darüber hinaus
nicht und sie stellt sich doch seitdem
der polnische Präsident du da gestern
nämlich sagte Polen sei bereit seine
Leopard 2 Panzer deutscher Herstellung
an die Ukraine zu geben Leopard
natürlich im Rahmen einer
internationalen Koalition schieb duda
noch hinterher die Grünen sind
grundsätzlich offen für diesen Vorschlag
entsprechend sollte Deutschland sich
nicht in den Weg stellen wenn andere
Länder Entscheidungen treffen die
Ukraine zu unterstützen unabhängig davon
welche Entscheidung Deutschland trifft
die SPD quält sich erwartungsgemäß nach
dem Schützenpanzer direkt über den
Kampfpanzer zu sprechen es gibt keine
roten Linien und von daher glaube ich
soll die Ukraine das bekommen was für
das Selbstverteidigungsrecht wichtig ist
gleichzeitig achten wir aber bei den
Lieferungen und ich glaube das sieht
auch eine große Mehrzahl der
BundesbürgerInnen und Bundesbürger so
nicht in den Krieg verwickelt werden
noch sei keine Anfrage zur Leopard aus
vor aus Polen eingegangen so Christine
Lambrecht die Linke aber fürchtet eine
Eskalationsspirale der Lieferungen was
ist denn das nächste die Forderung nach
Leopard sind auf dem Tisch irgendwann
wird vermutlich sogar Luftwaffe
eingefordert ich glaube Deutschland
sollte Führungsmacht bei einer europä
den Friedensinitiative sein die
politisch ohnehin angeschlagene
Verteidigungsministerin wird nicht
entscheiden ob und was Deutschland als
nächstes liefert das ist eine Frage an
Bundeskanzler Scholz
fragen wir gleich jakota in Berlin kann
sich der Kanzler diesen Druck überhaupt
noch entziehen also er bräuchte schon
ein ziemlich dickes Fell um diese ganzen
stimmen jetzt zu ignorieren
zumal sich die sogenannte Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe das sind die wichtigsten
Unterstützer Kiews in acht Tagen schon
in Ramstein trifft bis dahin wird der
Druck sicherlich aufrecht erhalten
werden auch von internationaler Seite es
kommen ja momentan fast täglich neue
Meldungen heute zum Beispiel eine aus
dem Europäischen Parlament dort liegen
offensichtlich schon zwei Anträge die
über die am Mittwoch kommenden Mittwoch
abgestimmt werden sollen die beide die
Lieferung von Leopard Panzern auch
fordern und einer dieser Anträge spricht
sogar Scholzen namentlich an und fordert
das der Bundeskanzler die Führung
übernimmt bei der Bildung einer
internationalen Koalition auch zum
Zwecke der Lieferung von Leopard 2
Panzern also wenn das nächsten Mittwoch
so kommen sollte dann wäre das das
nächste sehr deutlicher Zeichen von
internationaler einfach nur dass der
Druck also bleibt bis zum Rammstein
treffen dass er sich jetzt in eine
Führungsrolle begibt dass das wäre dann
eher überraschend das wäre ein
kompletter Rollenwechsel aber einem ok
zu einer möglichen Lieferung von
deutschen Kampfpanzern oder Kampfpanzern
deutscher Herstellung durch Drittländer
dem könnte er sich nur sehr schwer
entziehen zumal ja auch die SPD jetzt
schon das Signal gegeben hat dass sie
sich in einem internationalen Verband
dagegen nicht sperren wird ist also eher
die Frage wann er sich dazu äußern wird
und wie eine Frage der Zeit danke schön
für diese Einschätzung aus Berlin war
das
schauen wir in die Ukraine im Osten des
Landes ist die verlustreiche Schlacht um
Solidar offenbar noch nicht entschieden
das ukrainische Militär räumt zwar
bodengewinne der Russen ein doch
erleidet der Feind hohe Verluste sagte
Vize Verteidigungsministerin Maja das
ukrainische Militär halte dem Ansturm
weiter stand beide Seiten sprechen von
hunderten Toten neueste
Satellitenaufnahmen zeigen das Ausmaß
der Zerstörung intensiver Dauerbeschuss
hat ganze Landstriche in Schutt und
Asche gelegt
die Regionen in der Ostukraine steht
seit Wochen im Mittelpunkt des
Kriegsgeschehen besonders erbittert
umkämpft ist eben der Frontabschnitt um
die Stadt Solidar und das nur wenige
Kilometer entfernte bachmut von dort
berichtet Tim Krüger
von weitem sieht dieser Stadtteil von
bachmut ruhig aus die Kämpfer aber sind
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt der
gefechtslam der Krieg allgegenwärtig
erwähnte Ketchup bringt mit seiner
kleinen Hilfsorganisation mehrmals
täglich Lebensmittel Medikamente und
Wasser in die Stadt denn in diesem
Wohnblock etwa waren noch immer Menschen
aus die Gefahr fährt immer mit
wenn ich sehe dass das fliegt ich bin ja
ein normaler Mensch dann trete ich aufs
Gas und fahre schnellstmöglich Weg
die Menschen sind im dankbar denn das
Leben hier könnte kaum schwieriger sein
einige harren oben in den Wohnungen aus
die meisten aber haben sich in den
Kellern verschanzt
kommen Sie rein so leben bei uns die
Menschen hier unten das schwierigste ist
ohne Licht Gas und Wasser auszukommen
wir haben Kerzen und Taschenlampen die
aber gehen sehr schnell aus
sechs Bewohner schlafen allein in diesem
Raum der nur durch einen kleinen Ofen
beheizt wird trotz der permanenten
Angriffe der russischen Streitkräfte den
wollen sie nicht
hier sind unsere Häuser hier liegen
unsere Eltern begraben und außerdem
sollen unsere Kinder irgendwann hierher
zurückkommen können deshalb glauben wir
an den Sieg ohne daran zu glauben
während wir nicht geblieben
seit Monaten schon lieben die Menschen
in bachmut mit dem permanenten
kriegsdonnern und keiner weiß wie lange
sie noch unter diesen Bedingungen
durchhalten müssen
nach Nordrhein-Westfalen Tag zwei der
Räumung im Braunkohlegebiet Lutzerath
aus Protest besetzten klimaaktivisten
die Landesgeschäftsstelle der Grünen in
Düsseldorf in lützerath wurden
Holzhütten und Barrikaden mit Baggern
eingerissen und beseitigt viele Besätze
ließen sich ohne große Gegenwehr
wegtragen rWE will die Braunkohle unter
dem kleinen Ort für die Stromerzeugung
einsetzen im Gegenzug wurde der
Kohleausstieg auf 2030 vorgezogen
fragen wir Ralf Goldmann vor Ort einige
Demonstranten werfen der Polizei vor
unverhältnismäßig und mit Gewalt
vorzugehen wie schätzen Sie das ein
ja das erste was man sagen muss ist dass
dieser gesamte Einsatz doch relativ in
geordneten Bahnen und friedlich abläuft
und das sowohl auf Seiten der Besetzer
als auch auf Seiten der Einsatzkräfte es
gibt natürlich immer mal wieder Szene
bei ein Syndrom großen Einsatz wo sie so
viele Menschen gegenüberstehen die etwas
über die Grenze gehen das haben wir hier
immer wieder erlebt also Beamte sind mit
Feuerwerkskörpern beschossen worden mit
Steinen mit Flaschen mit Molotow
Cocktails aber auf der anderen Seite
sind natürlich auch viele Beamte relativ
rabiat vorgegangen vor allen Dingen wenn
es darum ging Menschenketten zu
durchbrechen oder Blockaden aufzulösen
der Einsatzleiter hat gesagt solche
Szenen wird es geben und zwar immer dann
wenn die Menschen hier Widerstand
leisten und das sei aber immer das
letzte Mittel also vorher versuchen man
zu kommunizieren und auf die Menschen
einzuwirken de eskalierend mit
kommunikationsteams und wo das nicht
klappt so sagt es zumindest die Polizei
da wird man vielleicht auch rabiatere
Bilder in Kauf nehmen müssen aber wie
gesagt der gesamte Einsatz verläuft im
Großen und Ganzen in geordneten Bahn und
der läuft sehr schnell man sieht hier
hinter mir zum Beispiel dieser
Holzkonstruktion die jetzt auch
demnächst geräumt wird das sind noch
einige Aktivisten aber die gesamte Wiese
die früher mal dieses Camp der
Aktivisten war die ist fast komplett
geräumt hier ist im Prinzip alles schon
in Schutt gelegt und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass es nicht mehrere Wochen dauern
wird so wie man mal gesagt hat sondern
vielleicht ein bis zwei Wochen wenn
nicht noch irgendwo unterirdische
Strukturen entdeckt werden die von denen
auch hier schon die Rede war und das
Wetter verlangt allen Beteiligten
einiges ab vielen Dank nach lutzerat
Ralf Goldmann war das
soziale Spannungen das fürchtet der
Mieterbund wenn der Staat nicht für mehr
bezahlbaren Wohnraum sorgt mit einem
Rekord Wohnungsmangel rechnet das
Bündnis für Soziales wohnen und fordert
vom Staat ein Sondervermögen von 50
Milliarden Euro denn bislang ist die
Bundesregierung weit entfernt von ihrem
Ziel für 400.000 neue Wohnungen pro Jahr
zu sorgen Silvia blessmann berichtet
es herrscht bauflaute in Deutschland und
das liegt auch an der drastisch
gestiegenen Energiepreisen hier werden
Mauersteine produziert aber der Absatz
stockt jede Wohnung die weniger gebaut
wird jedes Haus das weniger errichtet
wird kommt eins zu eins bei uns an und
wir rechnen mit einem erheblichen
Rückgang die riesigen Dampfkessel zum
Härten der Steine werden mit Gas
betrieben dessen Preis schwankt auf
hohem Niveau Bauprojekte sind kaum zu
kalkulieren aktuelle Berechnungen zeigen
es fehlen 700.000 Wohnungen Bund und
Länder müssen handeln fordern
Sozialverbände und Gewerkschaften es
wird seit Jahren nicht genug nachgebaut
und jetzt verschärft sich die Situation
einfach dadurch dass die Zuwanderung
deutlich angestiegen ist rund 1,5
Millionen Menschen mehr als vor einem
Jahr leben nun in Deutschland da statt
100.000 Sozialwohnungen nur 20.000 im
letzten Jahr gebaut wurden fordert das
Bündnis vom Staat dringend ein
Sondervermögen von 50 Milliarden Euro
aufzulegen und hier dem Mehrwertsteuer
von 19 auf 7% abzusenken die
bundesbauministerin erklärt die Preise
sind gestiegen wir haben
Milliardenpakete auch für die
Stabilisierung der Gas- und Strompreise
ausgegeben und wir sind jetzt in
ausnahmejahren und ich hoffe dass ich
spätestens 24 diese ausnahmejahre wieder
einigermaßen zu Recht ruckeln aber
erstmal wird das ja 23 auf dem Bau noch
ein sehr herausforderndes werden
ohne deutlich höhere Förderung scheinen
die ehrgeizigen wohnungsbauziele der
Regierung jedenfalls nicht erreichbar zu
sein
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock ist
für zwei Tage in Äthiopien einem der
ärmsten Staaten der Welt
das Land mit 120 Millionen Einwohnern am
Horn von Afrika ist zerrissen in der
Region tiegrei im Norden endete erst vor
kurzem ein blutiger Bürgerkrieg er
kostete Hunderttausenden das Leben fünf
Regenzeiten in Folge sind ausgefallen
jetzt herrscht eine katastrophale Dürre
Millionen Menschen leiden Hunger aus
Äthiopien Susann von Lojewski
fast wirkt es so als hätte es einen
Bürgerkrieg in Äthiopien nie gegeben
Kinder trainieren auf einem Skateplatz
in Addis abiba und träumen von ihrer
kleinen Zukunft wie so viele Kinder auf
dieser Welt
macht mich wirklich glücklich ich liebe
es einfach später möchte ich einmal
profiscaterin werden
um die große Zukunft
Äthiopiens geht es bei den Gesprächen
die bundesaußenministerin beerbock mit
dem äthiopischen premier Abi Ahmed führt
Abi einst ausgezeichnet mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis führte einen
erbitterten Krieg in der Region Tigray
mehr als eine halbe Million Menschen
sollen gestorben sein für bärbock ist
das besonders wichtig die
Ernährungssicherheit in Äthiopien
wiederherzustellen über 22 Millionen
Menschen sind mangelernährt Hilfe
hierfür kam von überraschender Seite es
ist bemerkenswert dass die Ukraine die
angegriffen wird hier Getreide für
Äthiopien spendet und Deutschland und
Frankreich unterstützen die ukrainische
getreidespende damit dass wir den
Transport hierher organisiert und
finanziert haben an der Seite von
Annalena beerbock ihre französische
Amtskollegin Kolonnaden es soll ein
starkes Zeichen einer geeinten EU sein
die Äthiopien nicht nur wirtschaftlich
helfen will die Ernährungslage in
Äthiopien ist das eine das andere aber
ist das juristische Problem solange
betriebsverbrechen von beiden Seiten
nicht verfolgt und dann auf bestraft
werden wird es einen echten Frieden in
diesem Land nicht geben
Feinde zu versöhnen und die Wirtschaft
wieder anzukurbeln
Äthiopien steht vor enormen
Herausforderungen um wieder zu einem
stabilen Faktor in Ostafrika zu werden
geheime Dokumente verschlossen in
privaten schränken das brachte
Ex-US-Präsident Trump in Erklärungsnot
und genau das bringt nun auch seinen
Nachfolger beiden in Bedrängnis die
Unterlagen aus beiden Zeit als
Vizepräsident fanden sich in seinen
privaten Büroräumen aber nicht nur dort
auch im Privathaus des Präsidenten
tauchten heute Regierungsdokumente auf
Claudia Betz
mit der Nachricht ist klar Joe Biden
gerät unter Druck weitere
Geheimdokumente aus seiner Zeit als
Vizepräsident sind aufgetaucht jetzt
sogar in seinem Privathaus in Delaware
wie bereits zuvor hier in einem früheren
Büro beidens seine eigenen Anwälte
fanden die Dokumente beim Ausräumen das
Justizministerium wurde informiert und
die Papiere dem Nationalarchiv übergeben
die Suche seiner Anwälte nach Dokumenten
sei nun abgeschlossen sagt beiden
die Menschen wissen dass ich geheime
Dokumente ernst nehme wir kooperieren
vollständig mit der Untersuchung des
Justizministeriums
Ex-Präsident Trump hatte hunderte
Geheimdokumente in seinem privat Anwesen
in Florida gehortet sich geweigert sie
zurückzugeben erst bei einer
polizeilichen Durchsuchung wurden sie
sichergestellt ihm droht deswegen ein
Strafverfahren jetzt ruft er wann gibt
es die Razzia in Joe bidens Häusern
vielleicht sogar im Weißen Haus
selbst einige Republikaner weisen auf
die Unterschiede hin hier wenige
Dokumente bei Trump hunderte und die
Reaktion bei beiden sofortige Rückgabe
bei Trump Behinderung und Verzögerung
die neue republikanische Mehrheit dem
Repräsentantenhaus wie genau diese
Unterschiede nicht sehen
der Kongress muss das Untersuchen ich
glaube nicht dass irgendein Amerikaner
denkt dass die Justiz nicht alle gleich
behandeln sollte
Joe bidens glaubwürdigkeit ist
erschüttert das Justizministerium wird
sich in diesen Minuten äußern
ein Glück das Jeff Beck nicht auf seine
Mutter hörte sonst hätte er Klavier
gelernt so aber baute er sich eine
Gitarre aus Zigarrenkisten und wurde zum
Gitarren Gott wie in die Times nennt
allerdings kein ganz einfacher Gott sein
Credo wenn ich nicht in jedem Song
mindestens zehnmal die Regeln breche
habe ich meinen Job nicht anständig
erledigt mit 78 ist Jeff Beck in London
gestorben Andreas Stamm erinnert
einer der größten oft im Schatten der
großen 1965 suchen die jardbirds Ersatz
für Eric Clapton
und finden Jeff Beck
bester Blues Rock Becks eigene Band
ebnet später den Weg für einen Weltstar
Rod Stewart
der wie auch andere Legenden Youtube
Ozzy Osborn Ronny wood Mick Jagger Zoll
den Gitarrengott im Netz Tribut
der große Jimmy Page die Ikone Clapton
vor allem die englischen Gitarrenhelden
sagen Jeff konnte auf einer Art Spielen
von der sie nur träumen durften
nicht die Verkaufszahlen zementieren
seinen Status sondern der Einfluss auf
Generationen von Gitarristen
[Musik]
mit ihm Musizieren ein muss was sie
quält wie so oft sein größter Hit der
größte Albtraum
in Verbindung gebracht zu werden
es fühlte sich an wie im roten Kleid auf
dem Bus Dach durch London zu fahren das
war ich nicht
was er war rastlos Jazz classic Techno
Hauptsache mit Gitarre eigentlich
erklärte Eric Clapton einmal besteht
Jeffs Leben aus zwei Dingen Autos und
Gitarre spielen
wie kein Zweiter
[Musik]
wäre vielleicht auch die passende
einstimmungsmusik für die deutschen
Handballer bei der WM in Polen und
schwedengegner sind Serbien und Algerien
das dab-team ist heute in Kattowitz
angekommen und hat das erste Training
vor Ort absolviert das Team von Trainer
Alfred Gießler und will morgen einen
perfekten WM-Start hinlegen
mit leichter Verspätung setzte der
Flieger der deutschen
Handball-Nationalmannschaft heute Mittag
um 12 Uhr acht am Flughafen von
Kattowitz auf im Gepäck vor allem viel
Vorfreude
gegen die gegen die Franzosen da kam so
ein bisschen das Kribbeln schon die
Stimmung war gestern schon Training gut
und ich glaube alle freuen sich jetzt
das losgeht
trainingsolvieren auch hier die Stimmung
gelöst
Bundestrainer Alfred Gießler wird morgen
wohl aus dem Vollen schöpfen können
und das Spiel gegen Katha morgen Abend
live zu sehen bei uns im ZDF ab 17 Uhr
den WM Auftakt den gab's schon gestern
Abend der Weltmeister besiegte Polen im
Eröffnungsspiel die kohlgastgeber in
Kattowitz mit einem starken Auftritt am
Ende setzte sich die französische
Auswahl dann aber doch knapp mit 26 zu
führen 20 durch und sicherte sich im
Favoriten Duell der Gruppe B2 wichtige
Punkte
gestern die Männer über 20 km ohne
Podestplatz heute die Frauen über 15 im
Einzelwettbewerb beim Biathlon
Heimweltcup in Ruhpolding wurde Vanessa
Vogt als beste deutsche Hälfte
Olympiasiegerin Denise Hermann Wick mit
love best Zeit nur 15 Punkte
Biathlon ist nun mal eine
kombinationssportart für Denise Hermann
Wick heute bittere Erkenntnis die
Laufform stimmt bei der Olympiasiegerin
aber drei Strafminuten im Schießen statt
sie nur ein 15er Platz
einfach ein bisschen verlassen und ja da
wollte ich einfach auch nicht fallen und
das ist dann im Einzel ist drei einfach
zu viel beste deutsche Vanessa Vogt auf
rangel 11 bewusst langsames schießen
führt bei ihr zu lediglich einen Fehler
hat schnelles Laufen und fehlerfrei es
schießen diese Mischung klappt bei der
Italienerin dieser vitozi am besten
folgerichtig hier zweiter weltcover
folgt nach 4 Jahren siegespause
das war zum Sport
das Wetter bringt Sturm und Regen
teilweise ergiebig warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst für eine Regionen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mehr gleich von
östindelli das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers um Viertel vor 10 und
hier begrüßt sie morgen Mitri Siren
einen schönen Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter es geht regnerisch
weiter denn schon das nächste Tief steht
an und das bewegt sich nach Osten und
das Regengebiet was dazugehört das
überquert uns südostwärts am alten Rand
gibt es sogar etwas Schnee ansonsten
morgen am Tag Verlauf zahlreiche Schauer
in der Nacht also schon verbreitet stark
bewölkt und mitteilst kräftigen Regen
nach westenen es kann durchaus ergiebig
sein und dieser Regen wandert langsam
nach Südosten aber der Wind kommt aus
südwestlichen Richtung ist kräftig und
Richtung Nordsee sogar mit Strom
die Temperaturen dazu zwei bis vier Grad
nach Südosten hin 10° Richtung Oberrhein
und morgen weiter schauen die nach
Südosten ziehen und auch im Nordwesten
gibt es neue Schauer teils mit Gewittern
Sturmböen wieder Richtung Nordsee ja die
Temperaturen 7 bis 11 fast 12 Grad zum
Beispiel am Oberrhein die nächsten Tage
vor allem am Samstag wird es sehr windig
werden und mit ergiebigen Regen bei 5
bis 12 Grad Sonntag ebenfalls weiterhin
durchwachsen und Montag gehen die
Temperaturen zurück ein schöner Abend